let's start over we got kalila gilbert
welcome to tiger belly thank you
george
beautiful bryce oh wow wow and we have a
[ __ ] guest tonight um
he literally is um one of my favorites
um
the ugly king of the east
the east yeah
he's a red nut
that's what i call him rednut
he's got like uh
some freckles i call him visual aids
oh it looks like disease
[Music]
he's so racist he talks about chinese
people
all the time right yeah when he has for
a while dude chinese eyes
there he goes there we go
um he's been on many many tv shows he
was on a very successful tv show called
mixology
it was a hit
he got canceled before it's time
really mixology
google it dude it's like a good show
it's one of the ones
and um he's also
one of the he's one of the ones that you
have to not watch or watch
either way um
he's also
the star of many different things like
the um
what was that one with the um
with the
the room but the other one
the room they made the remake with the
uh franco
disaster artist disaster artist he was a
big star in that
you know he had a monologue in there
that was like unbelievable anyway um
but he's also the star of i'm dying up
here which is a showtime show about the
comedy store a very good show very good
show he has his own podcast called
whiskey ginger uh-huh
and uh yeah yeah yeah
his name is andy santino give him a
round of applause everybody
welcome now you can talk
what's the matter what's the matter
yeah go ahead breathe breathe through it
it's a pleasure to be here
thank you thank you so much for having
me on didn't know you're gonna really
appreciate you know you're gonna be on
today you also don't have a single
freckle yeah i don't have any uh bobby
just uh makes up stuff to make him sound
funny and sweet bobby you gave me a bad
intro for the first time in our
friendship
what do you mean
mixology you talk about my cancelled tv
show
can i just say this the room the
disaster is a movie i literally got cut
out of
entirely yeah
i'm dying up here yeah my show that
literally just got canceled yeah
okay can i say this though no yeah no
i'll tell you why go ahead cause it's
your show this is your room it's your
girl it's your crew i get it your mics
your camera on a vacuum i get it
oh you misunderstood me friend
oh no i got it yeah oh my god
that song what that song i sang yeah
before right right was about you
by me and you walking down the street
yes okay all right i take it all back
oh
in my head i saw you skipping down the
street with like a bag of swedish fish
that's what it looks like
just like popping them in your mouth
yeah yeah happy together
it's the bag of fish that you were
excited about
the song was about you and could i say
this to you i'm happy to be here
that i think it was like five or six you
asked me to audition for another movie
you were doing it
it was an audition it wasn't it was an
offer and i was a straight offer yeah
the dialogue was so broken the asian it
was so thick yes right yeah i just kind
of passed on it and i felt bad because
yes you know i mean i love him and i
want to work with him again yeah but i
just didn't feel it mm-hmm
who who got the job before we go into
that yeah that kind of hurt my butt a
little bit it did yeah
and i felt that it did maybe how do you
you could have texted me
mm-hmm
oh wow all right all right
all right let's get let's go there let's
go let's go let's go now hold on yeah
obviously he wasn't with him he isn't
with me character defect 91a um no
but the thing is about the movie and it
wasn't a great movie and it didn't
theatrical almost did it didn't and but
now it's in reruns all the time
it was called the hungover
games
and so it was
kind of almost like we're doing with
cern talk it was like the guys from the
hungover yeah i know what it was woke up
yeah yeah no and they were in
what's that place and uh yeah in the
hunger games yeah yeah they woke up
there yeah and aura
anyway so it was like a parody
your character
was
the ken john character what's his name
yeah yeah yeah hangover you were mr chow
yeah but it was like super over the top
bad
on purpose it was like an alternate
[ __ ]
so it was like why is he going over the
top yeah you understand who got it
that fan
is that a bad word here
dad is the sweetest guy the sweetest guy
in the world sweetest guy in the whole
world friendliest guy he's so friendly i
think he won the thing yeah he won the
thing yeah um he won and he was the
nicest guy i haven't talked to him in a
while yeah i have no idea your history i
don't know mesa turned from white to
pink
robot went shut down mode
he went back farther in the closet
yeah yeah he came in he read a bunch of
times that's great
i have like i
i like him
in fact we love him so we love him so
much is that we talk about him a lot
because he loves the show yes have we
met him on the show he will never do it
wow there's some kind of thing there's
nothing there is nothing really he'll
never do it i'm doing it does that
matter okay you had jordan do it
all right i don't all right there's
obviously a thing that just stops us all
right so i just want to say that i just
want to say this okay
i'll shut up they're just i'm just going
to say this and i'm not making fun of
anybody i'm not this is not i'm watching
what i'm saying i just [ __ ] took down
true tv i'm [ __ ] no you're not very
good i liked it okay
this is that
you and jordan
right mm-hmm
you guys are wearing they are in movies
and [ __ ]
that's it that's all i'm gonna say
we have
you know a guest here that
i didn't know we're gonna have today
we were gonna have somebody else but
that somebody fell out
due to um a busy schedule
and we have somebody that i've known for
44 years no 45
44 years 44 years i've known that 32
years no that's 32 years 44. is it 32 or
44. i'm 32. you're not 32. you're
forgiving me do you believe i'm 44. i
mean you look like are the cameras
can we turn the cameras on now
look at my
skin look at my goddang skin i know
god's death yeah 32 yeah all right he's
32. sure then i'm 35. i agree with you
am i 35.
look at my skin 38.
i'll give you
you're gonna keep
so we've got my brother you really are a
reverse aging when you pull uh when you
poked your head through the door talk to
me yeah i was like holy [ __ ] yeah you
are you look younger yeah the last time
i saw your girlfriend you're like she
says the right things
yeah you are um
you're benjamin bulton i love it you do
right i love life
oh shut up [ __ ] up about life i want to
first make an amendment no i haven't
introduced you
before you do that i want to make an
apology yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm kalylah
i'm sorry for bringing kirby it was not
mindful for me to check with you first
it's fine i won't do it again it's fine
you know what that is right you know
what i call that 10 years of sobriety um
give him a round of applause my
girlfriend just celebrated 10 years of
sobriety
yeah what wait old steve how are you old
steve was like [ __ ] her
kirby stays and all that stuff no i
really no no i realized i had a partner
i should have that would be that but
that's really your attitude that bugged
me it was his
you know what i mean
you know what can i i love this guy so
much his life's good
i love him so much his life's good his
life's good
good life man financially stable yeah
he needs like therapy or he needs to
start going to more meetings
now let me say something i'm monotone
bob right now yeah right but you don't
want me no i'm like the hawk though what
do you mean what do you mean no i'm not
i'm just saying
i'm doing it i don't know i know but
monotone bob right if you enrage him
enough he turns into regular bob oh yeah
all right so right now
and there's veins sticking out of
monotone's bob's face yeah he's turning
a little green but not fully green and i
haven't grown so let me say something
what the [ __ ] do you mean by that
no i think it would help you though yeah
because
what's wrong with i have no anger
you do though i mean you you want to
talk about anger i i have a therapist
but he has been seeing somebody i have a
therapist doctor who troy
did you just korean yeah that's amazing
yeah i feel like that's perfect he
probably understands the korean family
dynamics and the rage
yes and he used to yeah and he uh yeah
he's he's he understands the asian uh
yeah can i say this though right now
yeah and i'm not
just between you and me right i'm not
gonna say nothing i swear to god i'm not
and i'm not i'm just saying
that
you could talk about dr troy all you
want i could say a couple of things
right now to get you back
don't wait
i'm not gonna do that i'm not gonna do
that but i'm going to tell you right now
dude right now look at me right now
right i have a couple of words i could
say i know i can get you back i know
into a rage mode and i'm not going to do
that
i'm not going to i'm just telling you
that i have the tools i know you oh just
as well
hey guys quick [ __ ] rewind the last
time we all did a podcast you put him in
the red zone and i don't want that i
know we're not doing that right now i'm
just letting you know oh yeah that's
that's right
your brain works i know
you know what you're like what penguin
wait what yeah
yeah
yeah oh yeah you're the penguin dude i
always thought he was the creepiest of
all villains yeah until to this day
anyway really good to see you
really thanks for doing it stephen lee
is my guest here on potagobella really
good to see you okay yeah i'm fine
i'm
who doesn't need therapy
you don't need it yep
gave it so
look at me right now look at me right
now look at me right now dude look at me
right now who's the healthiest guy
you've ever met in your life not you but
you don't need it no
i don't need it i don't need it i don't
need it though right but you do need to
go to more meetings no no who doesn't
need who doesn't need to go to a more
meeting
at least once or twice okay that's good
that's fine that's fair
once or twice congrats on 10 years
yeah yeah yeah
the middle thing i'm saying right now
man is is that i've always thought he
was one of the best
um he just did rogan's podcast he has
the best instagram in the market right
now
it's so [ __ ] funny his impressions
are [ __ ] dead on okay
and that's my impression i'm not done
sorry i thought what i [ __ ] said man
what did i [ __ ] say man i i thought
you said the dog bar no i said not to
say anything until and you were doing
fine because i'm about to say your
[ __ ] name that was a great intro too
i'm sorry i know because i'm starting
overnight see the whole thing over here
i'm doing the whole thing over now are
you serious yes i am do the countdown
it's like a thing you want the slow
countdown too very slower slower yeah
really
five
four
three
i'm emancipated and coagulated through
the utmost supreme being of my mind
we're upwards and downwards sideways
we're creating destinies and um
downtrodden
touching
creating
bilingual
um bystanders creating magic really to
be honest with you
go go
and um that was for england for winning
today
go go we've got um
we need this one right here
no this next co this next guest we have
is um
one of my favorite one of my favorites
and he um
he's just great and i i'm just glad he
was available to be here and he's been
on reno 909 and uh he has been on other
things and the reason why he sparked my
interest i was just
at the san jose san antonio um lol
comedy club and he was scheduled to play
i saw his little head shot there and he
winked at me the photo it was great wow
and i went you know what that's the next
guy let's get a round of applause for
kyle dunn again everybody clap your
hands now you may
yeah
all right i'm so scared
why i just don't know if i can talk yet
no problem i'm part of you know
everything is everybody's you know
everybody seems like it's more laid back
yeah yeah but angry white dudes you know
rolling by you know six seven well they
would probably call somebody too huh oh
they weren't calling anybody i mean the
only free finger they had they were
waving it out the window
yeah they weren't using it to dial the
phone so you [ __ ] on a frisbee out of
[ __ ] in the open now the yeah not the
top part but the bottom part a frisbee
is basically a cup basically the size
oh a plate it's a plate a plate well a a
plate is just a cup that's wasted
yeah i pulled over the car i think
honestly i'd run out again just [ __ ] on
the ground why did you have to be like
yeah so it's dark [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
guy [ __ ] in a tunnel you please [ __ ]
okay you should be familiar with tunnels
dude why huh because of vietnam
because you're gonna do that [ __ ] again
right now man what [ __ ] bro
why are you why are you oh no no dude
you're doing that nom [ __ ] again huh bro
what numb what you thought that i was
digging tunnels in the ho chi minh trail
and trying to attack you people no i
thought you think that was the fruit
juice the pomegranate fruit juice that's
always in there
palm yeah no
i got those and um yes i was very
excited that you were coming because i
haven't seen you in a while and how's
your podcast going it's going great but
can i just bring something up i i
noticed when i came here i'm like oh you
know bobby he's a very successful
stand-up comedian he's uh he's got a new
show he's making a lot of money
and uh i'm surprised that you're still i
i commend you for being in the same
small apartment okay
okay but a
it's hard to all fit in here to be
honest with you yeah and that's not the
problem i listen i'm i live modestly i'm
saying this you better beautiful home
from small
i got small money i'm saying no i'm
saying that it surprises me that then
you show me a six hundred dollar pair of
when you could have had a maybe a two
bedroom um i would like to educate you
because you're being confrontational and
oh no no and i will war with you
verbally i'm looking out for you no i'm
looking out to for me as well
and i'm defending myself okay okay i
still smell you're a [ __ ] arrogant
jew
do you think i'm an arrogant jew first
of all i'm not even religious i missed
yom kippur in fact i ate more during yom
kippur than i ever ever
in the way
[Music]
so let me just kind of just define
myself we did make an offer on a house
it didn't work out so i'm we're looking
again right now
we are we're looking again right now and
we're getting in the house within the
next three or four months where where do
you think you're gonna live nor muscle
yeah dude your lady is on a
moscow you could you watch
yeah but i know where honey comes from
you know so we both win you guys we both
lose where did you say honey comes from
what was your honeycomb the woods
yeah in the woods but in honeycomb yeah
honeycomb yeah where does that come from
you cook you call me you want to call me
glucon
you guys edited that in there
yes you did and we have it on [ __ ]
factual files dude
okay that's not a real thing factual
style i like that actual file yeah i
make words up bro
isn't there a drawing that's supposed to
happen right now downstairs in the ship
lobby can we [ __ ] get him a a job
that's getting out of hand the buffet is
closed yeah
ladies and gentlemen uh the buffet is
closed well we were in hawaii a lot of
people do look like you like the service
people yeah a lot of filipinos work on
the cruise ships you know there's no
even in the hotel they all just kind of
have your like bland look whoa it's not
bland i don't know
yeah why did you call me bland theo i
didn't at all i feel like it's kind of
an island mahogany oh i like that right
but if you like worked at a you know in
hawaii i could see it like an abc's like
if you saw me in a hotel you know
working there you'd be like yeah that
guy's weird nobody can imagine you
working first
i think kind of thing that's so rude
that you even say something like that
let me say something right now okay let
me i used to work on a farm
did you know that an ant farm no no
[Laughter]
oh my
that's cute
that's cute man no man a real farm man
oh yeah what are you guys growing dude
honey
corn dude oh really heard of corn yeah
yeah i used to work at a farm i used to
work at a farmer's market
i used to wear are you just at a
pharmacy are you just saying things that
i don't know i used to work construction
i used to wait tables i used to do a lot
of jobs did you really i was a hard
worker
okay
i don't it's only when
showbiz got in my vein
that i haven't really worked one vein i
believe that part have you worked you
have one thing
one way in one way out hey upper lip
thin yeah
dude my lips still growing dude unless
lester holt has a very thin upper lip
and he's got a good kick oh yeah yeah
yeah he does
you didn't even know what the [ __ ] i was
talking about
go ahead do
yeah
so i'm like oh i go whoa who are the
comedians and she goes well you know i
don't like dice i love dyes but sick
guys he was okay a lot of women and i
and i go okay but there was a girl
before
that went up and i go uh-huh she was
very funny
and in my head i dies and then when she
said there could only be one
you know
and i'm like it's my second ex-fiance
yeah i know and i go is it and i googled
you
is it her
she could that's her
right
so then when i see her you know later a
couple days later
i'm doing a podcast and i go in and i go
hey interrupts the podcast i interrupted
i just walked in and i go hey
hair lady you know she was at the vegas
and she said you you're great and you go
uh-huh
like you didn't i go thanks man yeah i
know you that was you
first of all you [ __ ] on it the whole
time thank you
what you [ __ ] on it the whole time then
gave the compliment like no way it can't
be it can't be that somebody saw eleanor
and she was good [ __ ] her i hate her
i gave you a compliment i'm like you
didn't give me a compliment she did yeah
but i had that information i know but
that information you just reiterated it
to me don't come at me i know i'm just
saying that i know you were [ __ ]
okay i know but can i just say this
though all right is it i didn't have to
give you that information you could have
kept it inside yeah but i wanted to make
you feel good i want you make you feel
good
and i go and i go i'm to make this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and make me feel good
right
[ __ ] this filthy [ __ ] white [ __ ]
and so i throw it out there and i just i
didn't like the response but that's all
but you know we're good wait did it
really hurt your feelings because i
didn't mean to but we were on a podcast
so you know i'm [ __ ] awesome yeah no
i liked it i was kidding well my top
five probably have you seen old boy yeah
the korean one it's not that great yeah
the korean one
is that where they're all fighting in a
school
you just said no
that's battle royale yeah i saw that
yeah but yeah but that's also japanese
yeah but also [ __ ] [ __ ] head i didn't
say that oh god yeah no guy
what i'm saying i was in a movie like i
didn't like it that's not the movie i
said
what movie did you say oh boy man okay i
don't watch it oh yeah i know but what
i'm saying to you white is to watch it
whoa whoa i will try and watch watch it
i've seen the advertisements it doesn't
look that great advertising yeah there
is no advertising yeah like i hated her
that i'm i'm being real right now yeah
no and i appreciate it yeah yeah but
then when i became a con i was like okay
i'm gonna be professional because to me
i was raised technically by mitzi in the
comedy store yeah where it was the
comedy store not the waitress store
nobody gave a [ __ ] about the wait staff
or the dorga the comics were important
so it's he was a hierarchy technically
so i'm like can't [ __ ] with that in my
head so one time he came in to do a i
was hosting open mic and he came in to
do a spot oh gosh and i was so nervous
and i think i mentioned every single
thing you've ever done
yeah like ridiculous like it was almost
overboard and at the time yeah ari fear
and you hadn't made up yet and ari was
sitting in the audience so many battles
yeah i know
so so you know it's so imagine now i
you know what you know what guys you
know what i'm gonna tell you this right
now i've been in battle
okay yeah and i'm a [ __ ] warrior for
life and i'm not gonna make excuses for
that okay all right
that's it all right yes i'm a liar
i'm a deceiver
but let me say something it's all based
we have a commercial break
commercial break yeah what is it what is
it who's our sponsor we also go to
burning man right yeah
do you go every year i went three years
in a row i didn't go this year but the
last three before that i regretted not
going this year i really i wait i woke
up every morning going why aren't i
there and who do you go with uh first
year i kind of went by myself
and
the second year i went with my buddy
michael rosenbaum and then last year i
went with my buddy dan and uh
i think i'm gonna go next year you know
it's funny i there's such a stigma
you know on like just people who go to
burning man in general like you know the
la types but i never if there was a
you seem like the perfect person to go
to burning man with if i ever if i could
ever think of anybody i would want to go
with you seem like nope
nope
she's not going with you i already said
she is
yeah but she's not going to do it that
would be i would allow it
selfish yeah i am selfish and when it
comes to that dude
why can't i take your girlfriend away in
a camper
for five days
what's wrong with you
guys that's my girl okay yeah
what
okay okay mr scrooge
humbug did you just call me mr scrooge
bro yeah why can't i spend a week in a
camper with your beautiful girlfriend
what would you do what would you do out
there with her in the desert ask her
what would you do with harlow williams
we would just
waltz around the playa i'd cook good
food maybe
you know
hey wait you don't need to know
i do need to know man because i know you
out there they don't take money they
trade services what you want to get a
sandwich you're going to sell her a
little [ __ ] out what i don't i can't
tell him i know just stop right now whoa
bro
you want a sandwich you're going to sell
my little girl's [ __ ] out his eyes are
brought to you huh
for a [ __ ] meatball sandwich
you won this round i know i didn't i
know i didn't won this right and don't
do that dude that's a [ __ ] human
being right there man
[Laughter]
i didn't see that coming let's go to
burning man i'm not i'm never gonna go
to burning man for the rest of my life
why i don't like it i don't like the
desert i don't like um fire i don't like
drums have you ever had sushi yeah
before you had it did you